this is two more Hussein standing in for
reviewer David Walt goose combat really
last longer than a handful of rounds in
the u.s. XCOM in each encounter chimera
squad kicks in the door dives headfirst
into an intense firefight and then walks
out through a pile of bodies a minute or
two later dusting themselves down a
little scarred perhaps but eager to do
it all again in the very next mission X
comes turn-based tactical combat now
comes in a condensed form relieved of
extraneous matter and for the most part
all the better for it assuming the human
resistance triumphed in X come to the
eponymous chimera squad is a special
task force composed of human and alien
soldiers that also serve as a symbol of
a newfound cooperation between species
dissidents remain however and so when
the mayor of city 31 is killed in a
terrorist attack it's up to the squad to
track down those responsible the stakes
feel a lot lower than the global
emergencies gripping previous X comms
yet the smallest scale of the situation
dovetails perfectly with the tight-knit
group of characters under your control
and intimacy of the tactical maps on
which they're deployed there's a focus
and clarity of purpose here that stands
in sharp relief to the sprawling saga of
the typical XCOM campaign chimera score
feels like it spins the geo scope and
puts just one city under the microscope
nine districts comprised a strategic map
each day highlighting a few of them with
new missions to undertake some advancing
the story others providing valuable
resources and gear ignoring one mission
in favor of another will raise the level
of unrest in the neglected district and
contribute to a citywide measure of
Anarchy that spells game over if it tops
out despite the lower stakes there's
still an urgency to your missions
especially as the Doomsday Clock of city
Anarchy takes closer to midnight and the
strategic layer does a decent job of
forcing decisions over which missions
and districts you need to prioritize
even if it's mostly a dry game of
resource allocation that fails to evoke
any kind of emotional response to the
live sacrifice along the way chimera
squad performs better when bringing to
life the characters of the squad itself
elevators have been out for
so you get to take an alternate form of
transport to the top if you say the
water main I'll strangle you beyond the
initial gang of four there's a roster of
eleven named soldiers to be recruited
over the course of the game each of whom
boasts a unique set of abilities that
are unlocked as they gain experience and
I really mean unique no two abilities
are the same even when the broad roles
they perform are similar the specifics
cunningly conspired to demand separate
tactical considerations
across the cost of 11 characters with
seven abilities each five of which can
be earned in any one playthrough
that's an impressively diverse tactical
lineup one that succeeds in edging
distinct personality traits on each
soldier through the substantial
differences in their play styles adding
further character definition are the
clever ways a soldier's loadout is both
limited and given flexibility weapon use
is restricted to just one class but guns
can be outfitted with multiple mods and
on later missions you can discover
one-off named weapons that confer a
unique herbally on its owner missions
are designed around short sharp bursts
of action and often split into multiple
but no more than three encounters
confined to a handful of rooms that in
themselves are much smaller than any map
you'd find in recent ex-cons
the tactical choices start with the
breech for your decisions over who
enters by the main door the side window
the skylight the eminent hole in the
wall and so on have immediate
consequences here you're determining the
order in which your soldiers take their
turns in the initial phase the boss they
can apply and the positions they'll take
up once the fight gets underway all of
these choices are vital get them right
and you'll tip the balance in your favor
get them wrong and you'll have learned
some lessons for next time there's a
coarseness to the feel of the tactical
combat that contributes to the sense
every decision Mars actions are big and
definitive outside of the odd boss
encounter you're never whittling away at
an enemy's health bar shot steel damaged
by the wallop and you can down many
folds in one - or occasionally three
hits abilities can often be more
impactful than standard attacks to the
extent that I complete plenty of
missions without firing a regular shot
recognizing when the stars have aligned
for you to deploy that battle turning
herbally is an important tactical asset
being able to plan ahead and in the
space of a turn maneuver your squad and
the enemy into position to take full
advantage of that ability is invaluable
not to mention endlessly satisfying when
you pull it off
less satisfying is the addition of
androids to provide support to your
squad if while on a multi encounter
mission one squad member bleeds out
you're able to replace them with an
Android for the next encounter I played
through the campaign on the noir
difficulty and called upon a replacement
Android just once thus rendering the
resources I invested in upgrading them
pretty much wasted I needed their
service more frequently on the higher
difficulties but I couldn't shake the
nagging feeling that anything I invested
in backup groups would be better spent
on my collar squad on the occasions one
of my elite squad members went down the
untrained Android sent in their place
simply wasn't up to task there's an
uneasy balance here one that left me
feeling like I could only make poor
decisions and it's the one area where
the tweaks the XCOM formula aren't
obviously successful by stripping back
XCOM combat to its bare minimum chimera
squad is able to make nearly all your
choices vital this isn't a series of
small choices that slowly accumulate
into something interesting it operates
more like a one-two punch of big
decisions you don't spend any time in an
encounter here patiently edging forward
stationing your squad on overwatch and
wearing the enemy down instead the enemy
is right there in your face from the
jump and you've got to act now and
decisively
luckily the chimera squad is there to
back you up